احنا نسال سؤال انت كخبيره بالموضوع هل
بالفعل للاخبار المزيفه والكاذبه لغه يمكن
ان تكشف
يعني بحسب الخبره يعني بنشوف فيها الاخبار
المزيفه بنلاحظ انه النصوص اللي بتستخدم
واللغه التي تستخدم بالاخبار المظله او
المزيفه همم بتعتمد مختلف يعني بنلاحظ انه
تستخدم لغه عواطف اوقات لغه ركيكه تستخدم
دائما صيغه المجهول او النفي همم الغضب
همم يسيطر احيان كثيره يعني فينا نقول انه
الاوجه تبع همم
تختلف بحسب هدف المنشور المدمر
هل من خدمه معينه برنامج معين يمكن الحديث
عنه لكشف الاخبار المزيفه مثلا انتم في
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه هل تتبعون هذه
الوسيله
نعم هلا ناحيه اللغه بعد
برنامج محدد كرمال نكسف هذا الموضوع ولكن
في ادوات وتقنيه اخرى بتعمل هي بتكون
مفتوحه المصدر نحن بنعتمدها للكشف مثلا عن
الصور عن المقاطع الفيديو او في مثلا امور
اخرى تستخدم
للنصوص ولكن لا نتحدثون عن اللغه
اللغه
لانه بيكون مثل ما سبق وقلت في لغه لغه
نحنا لم نعت انه نشوفها بالاخبار موثوق
بها وبالتالي الادوات والتقنيات اليوم او
البرامج لا تغطي اللغه بحد ذلك